it will hold my goodness he hangs in the
air then catches it watch the hang time
and then at the rim
Donovan
[Music]
skyhigh Boulder offensively how to get
it done and these steals another steal
10 steals now unselfish oh my I think
just takes a stare into the crowd
Mitchell it starts with defense mad
plain and simple fa just kind of flip it
over you're playing a catch O'Neal back
inside and there's Donovan with a throw
down on the paint
108 95 nearly 90-percent he's got a
steel which he is so good at inside one
off the [ __ ] is the Wookiee out of the
Mitchell from Rubio the eight to six
it's hard to root go in the steel and
the lob pass spot-on pass but just give
it to Donovan Mitchell he has Springs in
his legs he gets up with such
explosiveness the boy burger trapping
the pick-and-roll this time there's
stuff below she drives goes Mitchell
like an angry bird
and run him off those screens 4% 13 of
his last 22 from downtown nice Ben
Mitchell oh yes hammers down hammers it
home for two another lane watts Mitchell
killer cross and then the spin move off
and two-hand slam watch it under control
here Jeffries caught in the blender
nice move ball tipped icked up by Rubio
behind the back to Donovan finds it oh
all the rookie buries it with the right
hand times here he goes
to hit two feet and the one hand dunk
right on top of the rim watch out bars
here he comes
gh 61 three ball has been their friend
but they forced the chance of forced
turnovers and I there's a laugh and
Mitchell puts it down with two hands ten
love has that same match well Lovett
score seven of the
[Applause]
of him well Donovan Mitchell will he be
the Rookie of the month of December why
not with those type of plays he's on top
of the rim and more with ten on the shot
clock to Sefolosha cut pass inside
[Applause]
watch the back door cut here catches
Jerry Smith and manages incoming it just
attacks the rim with anger 9 is 15 from
the floor 20 points 6 rebounds
Donovan's tonight for a 10 from the
floor
he'll dribble drive inside and a flush
down and the rookie comes alive here
late in the fourth and satin wood shot
know where that happened I will fix it
up we just passed a 7-minute mark energy
[Applause]
the answer is yes it did Dabo put it
right on top and Donovan Mitchell with a
I'd say it loud the crowd in Miami and
I'm still wowed atop he goes falls 9 of
18 he's got 19 points but again he's
taken 18 shots to get his 1939 combine
the back for a back cut beautiful beam
up top on O'Neal
[Music]
Donavan off the turnover windmill how
about that maybe we'll show time in
Sacramento time the guys get at the top
of the key and that becomes a pass
sometimes I like the order back to
Donovan working host looks white by
[Applause]
Donovan now you have options or splits
those two guys gray screen set there by
director
you don't
z-bo not going to get in the way of that
that's it down a bun does a little smile
on that face why not hammers down
another bucket buddy hield
with a bucket come on now the yolk has
three dunks tonight for Donovan Mitchell
mom I just extending out into the
airspace not allowing these open threes
on the lobs uptown and they hammer down
by Donovan's you can throw it as high as
you want a that's above all right at the
square but I think Joe is cool Mitchell
on a breakaway hammers down the the two
and we got ourselves a four done block
it angles runs the trailer
pull the trigger look at this just kicks
it up and puts it down eleven point half
for Donovan just keep moving on top of
the rock
put it down young man
where you see Kimber gets turned around
and all of a sudden no one's there misty
was out there me free throw line
extended and he's all by himself he sees
during middle and he's swimmin to be our
score and sometimes facilitating it
gotta love this image
where is Mitchell
[Applause]
why
that was sweet sweet playing - wow what
confidence ever might be a team app to
happen here Donovan what a great steal
stepped right into bathroom life that's
jam and all of a sudden a little mini
500 Ron between the guys in little
Showtime jazz up six after one down
three if they have right now clinging to
a one-point lead Ivan put it down with
the right hand
let me just explode it to the rim this
play here was the one I was knocked out
on he what a move here he's gonna be
just surprised oh part I think by
dunking the basketball and then he goes
up very strong he played one year
Canton's big 12 freshman of the year
averaged 16 points
[Applause]
they clear out the side he comes Ingles
at the rim they catch Booker sleeping
and run away win against Phoenix he's a
terrific second half player we'll see
what he's got pumps the
[Applause]
but watch this steel lit world you just
see this pump it gets the defender to
freeze and put oh look at the wiggle
right there and the goal citizen but
that steel
[Applause]
long fast tingles going to his left
notice this on the left side of the rim
so Donnelly can catch it
coach Walt he realizes they only have
nine guys right Johnson bench drive
throws it down Tucker left enjoy the
lamp yes a two on one
Mitchell calls for the LOB and he slams
at home emphatically beautiful pass by
Christine
[Applause]
[Applause]
and when you get there you've got to
come in oh my goodness special play here
misses the little short little alley-oop
about the finish by the slam dunk
champion they're getting the shots they
want they're just not knocking them down
a little bit better than early on in the
first quarter little wild wild moment
what baseline and
Jovie Donovan Mitchell we talked about
his athleticism right here we've seen
plenty of those it just keeps going up
and up makes my knees vertical
effectiveness gets it back double pump
on go fair and Rudy goes down if I outer
takes it away
let's that rim protection blob oh my
Dante and Donovan three starts on the
defensive end Colbert straight up jazz
get the rebound and watch the pass
perfect pass lob and look how high
Mitchell gets and they're competing -
they're competing at both ends
[Applause]
yes the end here comes our play of the
day tomorrow unbelievable about this
shot look at the explosiveness with the
left hand to right and extends and puts
it home this would be a nine in a dunk
contest Poehler much less in a game look
at the explosiveness of Mitchell half
against the Jazz in Dallas they go Lisa
go took it away from dungeons gets it
back puts up the shot wash down and he
gonna miss layup here he just kind of
hangs and then grabs it turns the ball
over he's in the air one one thousand
two one thousand on the 7o run over the
last minute to change angles put that
one down young fella
well Ricky Rubio doing a nice job
running this play Joe gets it up because
again the officials are looking not to
impede the offensive progress down but
breaks loose
maybe that gets Mitchell going Turner
who's done a really nice job off the
bench
this season not a very good passing type
quarters in court row with the steal
[Applause]
get it in the area code Donovan's gonna
find it that's incredible
do you caught that you know it's like
we're gonna be smart well like who does
anybody try to be dumb bill McGee is
seven to the rim will feel that one
tomorrow is again one of his sweet spots
he's 51% really important Paul his drive
he split the double-team and Donovan
told you guys would not under
appreciated under recruited before their
college years there's a steal by Donovan
Mitchell and he hammers it down Donovan
wants to get in the action but it's dead
back to Kuzma the top of it
first we got coach Kuzma no luck finding
Donovan on the dish
[Music]
Mitchell Wow I better lettuce isn't
right you're big you so long hand
floater
Donovan rebounds out to Joe jasm three
[Applause]
mister the paint I mean just slow down
the paint Oh jasny to the bucket dear
Donald Mitchell says I'm gonna make sure
we down if it saves it at midcourt 15 on
the shot clock
Reuter was big in the third goes up
splits right between Noel and goes nine
straight misses from the three losses
but
drives by side
[Applause]
well out of their feet by Mitchell this
is the dunk channel bringing you mr.
Mitchell with the legs spread out I mean
this is like nerf hoops type of stuff
bowler down in the basement you're a kid
you put it on a five-foot hoop and you
go up and you see what you can do
Mitchell's doing it on a 10 foot Oh
unreal Springs energy covers a lot of
mistakes but you have great energy and
so far let's see if the jazzman's about
this their borders like that the steel
watch out Joe right back to town minute
hammers home the first bucket of the
second half it's quick one and energy
out away the hassle steal and then they
get back down and the Bulls run with gun
will drive it inside I think they're
three
[Applause]
Rondo block by go there
picked up by Rubio that's his third
rejection Ruby L alley up the Mitchell
though that free agency versus Hornish
team doesn't make the playoffs here's
Donovan to drive inside
broken up rubio Onofrio to whose
official who slaps it turns it over
Gobert trying to hit ingles threw it
right to harden but then rubio picks
hardest pocket Eliot
[Applause]
whistle get off the rock is turned over
go young man that's the way to go up a
terrible pass and a wonderful what's up
you guys this Taylor Brooks with
bleacher report make sure that you
subscribe for some more video content
what's up you guys this Taylor Brooks
with bleacher report make sure that you
subscribe for some more video content